[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 7 juillet
voici les titres de cette édition
alors que la situation du variant delta
inquiète en ce début des vacances la
vaccination ne compte pas s'arrêter
durant l'été malgré la fermeture de
certains centres d'autres sites restent
bien ouvert en juillet et août et des
opérations éphémères seront organisées
aussi dans les yvelines ont fait le
point
les congés est l'occasion de se changer
les idées mais chaque année en france un
enfant sur trois n'a pas cette chance de
partir en vacances
focus tout à l'heure sur quartiers d'été
qui va à la rencontre des jeunes pour
des activités dans leur ville et nous
parlerons de cette thématique avec notre
invité pascal rodier secrétaire général
du secours populaire français des
yvelines
enfin direction le camp militaire de ben
dans ce journal fin de stage pour 30
cadets de la gendarmerie qui ont célébré
les pilotes de cette aventure par une
cérémonie
ces jeunes issus certains de quartiers
prioritaires ont pu découvrir l'univers
de la gendarmerie durant plusieurs mois
et dans ce journal on parlera aussi des
inquiétudes du moment dans la ville de
versailles suscitée par des soirées
dites projet x
[Musique]
vive inquiétude également autour de
l'émergence du variant delta les cas de
contamination sont repartis à la hausse
ce variant concerne en ile-de-france
54,1 pour cent des cas avec le
département des yvelines
particulièrement concernée elle le
gouvernement pourrait même réfléchir à
de nouvelles mesures sanitaires en
parallèle la vaccination elle continue
dans le département et se poursuivra
tout au long de l'été avec une
organisation établie
on fait le point avec bixente maria
santisteva les vacances d'été ne sont
pas synonyme d'arrêt de la vaccination
dans les yvelines avec environ 50 % de
sa population primo vacciner et dans la
crainte d'une nouvelle vague liés aux
variants delta des mesures ont été
prises pour permettre la vaccination du
plus grand nombre
tout d'abord le délai entre deux
injections qui était de 42 jours a été
assouplie il est dorénavant situés sur
une fourchette de 21 à 49 jours les
plages d'ouverture des centres de
vaccination ont été une fois de plus
étendu et il n'est plus nécessaire de
prendre rendez vous au préalable
ensuite bien que trois centres et choisi
de fermer définitivement d'ici fin
juillet à chatou rambouillet et
bonnières-sur-seine 413 ouvert tout
l'été ils sont situés au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines au centre
commercial de vélizy 2 à saint germain
en laye et à mantes la jolie
des opérations ponctuelles seront
également organisées tout au long de
l'été chronologiquement cela commencera
par le 11 juillet à la phase 2 de
trappes pour la finale de l'euro de
football
suivront les 16 et 17 juillet dans la
base de loisirs de verneuil sur seine et
sur les aires d'autoroute de
morainvilliers les 23 et 24 juillet
entre le 30 juillet et le 4 septembre
une opération au coeur des quartiers des
mureaux aura lieu et enfin du 24 au 26
août aux différents centres sociaux de
carrières sous poissy et depuis hier les
candidats au baccalauréat sauf s'ils ont
obtenu le précieux sésame et les
chiffres de cette édition 2021 ont été
dévoilés ce matin par l'académie de
versailles
toutes filières confondues le taux de
réussite au bac s'élève cette année à 89
6% dans l'académie qui comprend les
yvelines le val d'oise les
hauts-de-seine et l'essonne soixante
mille sept cent trente et un élèves ont
été reçus en tout est dans le détail 94
7% de taux de réussite pour le bac
général 80,7 7% pour les filières
technologiques 77,9 % pour la voix
preuve
sionnel une édition particulière crise
sanitaire oblige avec une grande part
donné cette année au contrôle continu
seules les épreuves de philosophie et du
grand oral ont été maintenus pour la
deuxième année consécutive le
département des yvelines réinvente les
vacances pour la jeunesse près de 45
activités ludiques et pédagogiques sont
organisés et du 7 juillet au 27 août ce
dispositif nommé quartiers d'été est
intégralement financée par la
collectivité on écoute caroline du plan
chef du service culture et territoire au
micro dé l'honore sinoquet le
département a souhaité mettre en place
de nombreuses actions à destination
notamment des populations les plus
fragilisées sel dans les quartiers
politique de la ville notamment
et chez nous aussi un public cible à
savoir les enfants de la zone est donc
l'idée c'était de monter un certain
nombre d'opérations pour pouvoir
permettre des activités sur le temps
estival des activités de proximité c'est
vraiment de vente et toutes les
richesses que propose deux départements
des yvelines
[Musique]
par rapport à l'année dernière on a
augmenté le nombre de partenaires sur ce
dispositif donc on est à 48 partenaires
que ce qu'ont proposé bien on propose
aussi bien des sorciers à l'accrobranche
de morainvilliers ou au nautic par nos
logis bac mais aussi la visite du
château dampierre ou de breteuil
on propose également des activités au
domaine de madame elisabeth qui est un
site départemental
on a la ferme nature et découvertes à
versailles ça ça fait partie des
nouveaux sites
on a réussi à avoir des visites au
centre de football de clairefontaine
aussi est ce qu'on a introduit cette
année en nouvelle activité c'est la
visite du patrimoine industriel donc on
propose des visites à manque la ville
des ateliers buffet crampon
on propose également des visites sur le
site d'ariane groupe au mur où on a
également l'entreprise bd comme qui nous
a rejoint comme partenaire
[Musique]
ça se déroulera les 8 et 9 juillet sous
forme d'ateliers ses destinées à la
maison de l'enfance des yvelines amante
l'idée c'est d'associer un lieu avec un
artiste pour faire une fresque en
collaboration avec des enfants donc
voilà cet événement c'est la première
fois pour le test c'est un partenariat
avec le centre pompidou et on est très
content de pouvoir aussi réaliser cet
événement-là en ouverture de quartiers
d'été l an passé trois mille jeunes et
500 accompagnant bénéficier de ce
dispositif objectif pour le département
et dépasser ce chiffre 80 % des
activités ont déjà été réservés mais il
reste des places disponibles
et pour ce faire rendez vous sur le site
alors on l'a pas qu'il y va s'affiche en
bas de l'écran mais le site ses
quartiers d'été point yvelines point fr
voici le site pour réserver les quelques
places disponibles qu'il reste encore
chaque année en france c'est un enfant
sur trois qui n'a pas la chance de
partir en vacances des associations sont
mobilisées pendant l'été pour permettre
à ces jeunes de pouvoir et bénéficier de
séjours et d'activités on en parle avec
mon invité pascal rodier bonsoir bonsoir
avec nous par visioconférence secrétaire
général du secours populaire français
dans les yvelines
cette période de l'été on va parler dans
un instant des conséquences de la crise
sanitaire mais on imagine que la période
de l'été c'est clairement une période où
on voit les inégalités entre les
familles les deux temps de l'année dans
notre calendrier à tous où on voit les
inégalités ont peut-être on les ressent
le plus durement c'est les vacances
effectivement puisque comme vous le site
y ait un enfant sur trois qui partent
pas en vacances ça fait quand même du
monde
et puis les temps de noël mais c'est
traditionnellement deux périodes de
l'année où on est un petit peu occupé à
notre niveau au niveau du secours
populaire
la crise sanitaire at elle justement
aggraver cette situation est ce que
aujourd'hui il ya plus d'enfants qui
risque de ne pas partir en vacances cet
été
en bas oui c'est évident déjà parce que
le contexte sanitaire est très incertain
encore pour beaucoup de monde c'est à
dire que c'est quand même très récemment
que ça c'est un petit peu allégés au
niveau de l'horizon pour y compris pour
n'importe quel particulier qui souhaite
partir en vacances
et de fait pour les personnes qui sont
en situation précarité qui sont habitués
à solliciter des dispositifs comme ceux
du secours populaire
cette incertitude sur le contexte
sanitaire il est vécu encore un petit
peu plus durement donc c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu angoissant pour tout
le monde puisque pour ceux qui ont la
chance de partir c'est au moins une
bouffée d'oxygène et si elle si elle
n'est pas garanti bah ça va être encore
plus durement vécu et c'est ce que
j'allais vous demander en quoi c'est
primordial de pouvoir partir en vacances
avoir cette chance là vous disiez
peut-être rompre avec le quotidien et
peut-être les problèmes que l'on peut
avoir aussi au quotidien ça permet de
s'évader en quelque sorte aussi de
partir en vacances
ça permet de s'évader puis aussi pour
les personnes que nous accompagnons
parfois aussi ça permet de se construire
et de se projeter dans le temps
c'est à dire que préparer un séjour de
vacances pour ces pour ses enfants pour
sa famille
c'est une manière de se projeter dans un
futur et parfois aussi d'acquérir des
petites bases d'organisation et on a de
plus en plus de gens qui ont des temps
très court en fait et qui se projette
pas à trois ou quatre mois un individu
qui est habitué à partir en vacances en
février il passait il passe ses
réservations pour l'été
là on a des gens qui continuent de nous
appeler on est rentré dans le mode
juillet vous avez combien de
bénéficiaires aujourd'hui ce que c'est
un chiffre ou lisier il ya des
conséquences de la crise sanitaire est
ce qu'il est en augmentation sur sur cd
à ces derniers mois ah oui sur les dates
sur les derniers mois on a dépassé les
10 mille donc on a eu une augmentation
sur un an et demi d'à peu près 45 %
alors il ya plusieurs actions qui sont
proposés par le secours populaire durant
cet été on va les présenter bien sûr
tout d'abord déjà des sorties qu'est ce
qui va être proposé justement pour ces
familles durant cet été en terme de
sorties
eh bien on participe on est partenaire
du dispositif qui a été évoqué tout à
l'heure le dispositif quartiers d'été et
on a aussi nos propres vecteur
d'organisation et sur les sorties rien
pour le mois de juillet on en a eu une
récemment à la cité des sciences qui a
déjà eu lieu
il va y avoir des enfants qui vont
participer à l'arrivée du tour de france
sur les champs elysées il ya une sortie
traditionnelle pour nos seniors chez gel
qui est prévu on va avoir une
participation un cluedo géant à
sartrouville
il ya des enfants qui vont découvrir
l'équitation on a une journée aussi ça
c'est une première on a une journée des
oubliés des vacances spécial jeunes 18
30 ans qui se tiendra le 27 et il y aura
150 pers 150 jeunes qui seront sur la
plage de cabourg et c'est des jeunes
qu'on a accompagné justement dans le
cadre de la crise qu vie de des
étudiants ou des jeunes salariés ou
qu'ont perdu leur emploi et qui ont été
contre à verser une période de précarité
où on leur a prévu au moins une journée
de détente avec aussi des des séjours
alors soit des séjours en famille aussi
des séjours des colonies de vacances
directement pour pour les enfants
notamment voilà ce ces deux types
d'actions également qui sont proposés si
oui alors le plus gros du dispositif
c'est le dispositif des colonies de
vacances puisque on est intégré dans le
dispositif des vacances apprenantes
c'est un dispositif d'état depuis la
deuxième année et sur cet été on a déjà
prévu
deux cent soixante deux voiliers comme
quoi sert peu précis de 162 enfants qui
vont être accompagnés sur une petite
trentaine de ces jours je crois c'est 26
ou 27 séjour qui s'étale sur juillet
août et donc bah il ya divers panel
d'activités qui sont proposés et divers
partenariats avec des organismes
professionnels et c'est des enfants qui
vont de sava de 6 à 16 17 ans donc là on
est bien bien sûr les starting blocks
puisque les premiers départs auront lieu
demain soir
et justement alors sur ses actions et on
en terminera par là vous avez besoin de
bénévoles notamment oui du soutien
logistique et notamment de la présence
en gare aussi un pur pour les bénévoles
concrètement quels sont vos besoins
aujourd'hui alors faut cliquer la
regarde et hop on a fait le lien et en
fait on a besoin de soutien
administratif un peu quand même aussi
puisque de 160 enfants qui partent ça
fait 260 dossiers et une trentaine de
séjour comme je vous disais donc il faut
bien tout contrôler que tout et tout est
bien rempli et sur le mois de juillet on
a une toute une série de dates donc là
j'emmenais qu'on doit avoir huit dates
sur lesquels on a encore besoin de deux
personnes ça consiste en fait à
accueillir les familles et leurs enfants
dans les gares ou au départ des bus
puisque certains séjours cesser par bus
que le départ se fait et donc on a
besoin de bénévoles du secours pour
rassurer un petit peu vers les dernières
mises à jour des papiers s'assurer qu'on
n'a rien oublié signer des papiers qu'on
aurait oublié récupérer le duo avec le
secours populaire va donner pour ceux
qui vont dormir dans des duvets sous les
tentes avala donc il faut pas hésiter à
s'inscrire on a vraiment besoin de monde
et pour vous contacter il ya les
coordonnées du secours populaire
français des usines qui se sont affichés
également merci pascal rodier pascal
rodier d'avoir été avec nous mais c'est
moi qui vous remercie secrétaire général
du secours populaire des yvelines
[Musique]
la direction versailles à présent un
phénomène inquiète autorités et
habitants depuis plusieurs semaines on
en parle avec vous et l'honneur sinoquet
bonsoir ça la rédaction de tv 78 ce sont
des soirées appelé projet x qui sont au
coeur de la discorde
c'est en effet sur la place du marché à
versailles grigori que depuis deux
semaines des jeunes se réunissent en
nombre le soir plusieurs centaines tout
de même comme vous l'avez dit ce sont
des soirées projet x donc c'est en
référence au nom du film américain qui
sont organisés et planifiés via les
réseaux sociaux les week-ends le
problème c'est soirée dégénère et se
transforme en affrontement entre bandes
comme on peut le voir sur ces images de
nos confrères de bfm paris le week-end
dernier le 4 juillet au soir des jeunes
ont même été blessées et deux
arrestations ont eu lieu tout comme le
week-end d'avant où une dizaine de
personnes avaient été interpellées
avec la violence cela pose aussi un
problème aux riverains et aux
commerçants de cette place qui dénonce
ce phénomène récurrent qui fait fuir
leurs clients certains riverains disent
même se sentir obligés de contourner la
place du marché pour rentrer chez eux
suite à cela le commissariat de la
police nationale de versailles a lancé
un appel à la responsabilité sur twitter
en demandant d'éviter les rassemblements
sans respect des gestes-barrières ou
encore de ne pas se mettre en danger
suite à plusieurs vols et rixes à ce
propos julien le cam secrétaire régional
du syndicat alliance police nationale 78
a réagi au micro de tv 78 sur ce nouveau
phénomène
il faut savoir que ce genre de soirée la
plupart des personnes qui viennent sont
sont des jeunes qui viennent d'ailleurs
qui sont dans un esprit plutôt festif
mais simplement on s'est très vite des
groupes hostiles se joignent aux fêtards
et c'est là que que les que les
événements dérape
la réaction c'est que malheureusement
cet événement qui était qui était prévu
à la dernière minute sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est fini dans dans la violence
par ça s'est fini par deux des
agressions c'est fini par des vols de
téléphones portables
et forcément c'est un peu
l'incompréhension si parmi les forces de
police ou jeunes fêtards de faire très
attention
1 faire très attention notamment par
rapport à leur téléphone par rapport de
même reste en famille et que s'ils
voient justement des groupes hostiles
on va dire arriver se joindre à la fête
de quitter mais mieux le plus vite
d'éviter justement de rester sur cette
place qui justement ge a attiré des
troubles fêtes et des individus parfois
très violents pour le moment pas
d'information sur une nouvelle une
troisième soirée et projet x qui serait
prévue à versailles grégory et pas de
consignes particulières non plus en ce
qui concerne les forces de l'ordre mais
rien n'est moins sûr à mon avis que la
police nationale sera en alerte ce week
end
merci à l'honneur pour cet éclairage
l'hommage de la ville de poissy à
présent à joël hier mardi sept agents de
la commune est décédé le 29 juin dernier
renversé par une moto une cérémonie
s'est déroulée à l'école de labruyère là
où elle exerçait aux côtés de parents
d'élèves d'agents et d'élus pisciacais
dont le maire de la commune karl olive
et joël bellec avait 64 ans cérémonie de
fin de stage pour les cadets de la
gendarmerie elle s'est déroulée vendredi
dernier au camp militaire de ben pendant
un an 30 jeunes âgés de 17 à 21 ans
suivi ce dispositif lancé en 2010 est en
ile de france
un moyen pour eux dont beaucoup qui sont
issus des quartiers politique de la
ville est de découvrir les métiers de la
gendarmerie juliette prigent une insigne
comme récompense
vendredi 2 juillet marque la fin de
stage des cadets de la gendarmerie
trente jeunes des ide
du val d'oise ont participé pendant un
an à ce dispositif
l'objectif faire découvrir les métiers
de la gendarmerie et tous en garde un
souvenir particulier je vois maintenant
quand on est tous soudés on marche main
dans la main et on partage tous le même
objectif c'est d'intégrer la gendarmerie
et ce qui fait justement on a une très
forte amitié qui s'est basé là dessus je
vais en garder un très très bon et un
très bon souvenir car je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'on vit pas tous ceux
dans une vie et je vais garder un très
bon souvenir
mis en place en 2010 est ce dispositif
est un partenariat entre la gendarmerie
l'éducation nationale et l'état
tous les volontaires sont âgés de 17 à
21 ans ils sont recrutés sur des
critères sociaux géographique de
motivation et de revenus beaucoup
d'entre eux sont issus de quartiers
politique de la ville je pense qu'il ya
un enjeu également d'information de
promotion de sensibilisation de ces
dispositifs dans certains coins de la
république on n'est pas totalement
informés de du panel de dispositifs qui
peut exister pour justement faire de
cette citoyenneté une citoyenneté active
grâce à un enseignement scolaire et
trois stages les cadets se prépare pour
le concours d'entrée de la gendarmerie
de quoi mettre un premier pas dans le
métier beaucoup de jeunes des fois ne
veulent pas s'inscrire aux concours
parce qu'ils ont peur tout simplement il
est 9h une hantise lie au concours or
ces jeunes ils ont des fois les
savoir-faire les savoirs qui permettrait
d'être de bons gendarmes donc cet
accompagnement scolaire
cette préparation concours vont leur
permettre justement de préparer le
concours et de l'obtenir les banques qui
puisse inspirer intégrer les rangs de la
gendarmerie en septembre le dispositif
va s'étendre 120 places seront ouvertes
dès la rentrée prochaine
90 places de plus que les années
précédentes se lancer dans l'auto
entreprenariat un challenge qui peut
paraît très compliqué dans la mode par
exemple difficile de gérer en plus des
créations la partie communication à
rambouillet une nouvelle plateforme en
ligne a été créée à cet effet elle
permet de mettre en relation directement
les couturières sur mesure avec leurs
clients leurs reportages d'astrid
bergère ça vous va met en relation des
créateurs de mode sur mesure et des
clients objectif de la plate forme en
ligne faire connaître des talents cachés
ça leur permet d'avoir
mini boutique en ligne et les clientes
entre leurs mesures ou scan leur mesure
avec leur téléphone portable
et ça permet de choisir un vêtement et
de le faire fabriquer sur mesure par le
créateur directement la plateforme a été
créé en juin 2021 de nouveaux créateurs
sont recherchées uniquement dans le haut
de gamme
on est vraiment ouverte à tous types de
créations originalité voilà avec un vrai
savoir faire derrière avec une
fabrication française avec pourquoi pas
lancer des jeunes créateurs on en a ici
qui sont qui sont up qui sont dans les
starting-blocks plusieurs et binoy ont
d'ores et déjà rejoint le projet un coup
de pouce pour ces auto entrepreneurs qui
n'ont souvent pas le temps de s'occuper
de la communication
on m'a gentiment invité donc muriel des
ans chanteuse et puis anne laure qui
m'ont sollicité pour intégrer la
plateforme
voilà c'était une autre manière de
travailler mais comme ça reste toujours
du sur mesure
la création et de la confection sur
mesure là ça me convient ça me convient
parfaitement
les locaux de la plateforme sont basés
dans l' espace de coworking smartcity à
rambouillet plusieurs créateurs se
trouve également sur place pour refermer
ce journal 2021 année anniversaire pour
le parc france miniature le site
installé à willencourt fête ses 30 ans
construit et boulevard andré malraux le
parle de répliques de monuments
nationaux en miniature a vu le jour en
1991 à l'origine du projet deux
passionnés on remonte le temps avec
justin braz est à l'origine de france
miniature deux visages tout est parti
d'un projet d'étude au moment où les
parcs de loisirs devenait un vrai sujet
en france
thierry col qui a souhaité ancrer un
d'un genre différent
à l'époque étudiant en économie et droit
du tourisme france miniature est devenu
son cas d'application concret son
associé alain pelras ancien ingénieur
passionné de trains miniatures est
arrivé sur le projet par sa passion du
modélisme ferroviaire
le projet a été entièrement réalisée sur
fonds privés
un investissement de 20 millions d'euros
objectif promouvoir le patrimoine à
l'architecturé créer un lieu culturel et
récréatif des arbitres donc promouvoir
d'expliquer la part de deux voilà de
mettre en en évidence la diversité des
paysages aux régions françaises le
projet crée une carte de france 2 5 ha
en i mode lan les reliefs rivières
fleuves mers et océans à l'échelle 1 2
centièmes le projet a nécessité 18 mois
pour réunir le financement et les
autorisations administratives
on a lui aussi a fait 18 mois au parti
en casquettes tâchant de creuser la mode
et les tâches lancé en même temps la
réalisation des maquettes et réalisation
d'animations quelques travaux et 18 mois
à sa création le parc disposait d'une
équipe de maquettiste en interne pour
réaliser les villages et installer les
maquettes au sein de leur écrin paysages
et les monuments ont été réalisées à
l'échelle 1 30e par une soixantaine
d'artisans partout en france à l'époque
difficile à d'avoir des plans
opérationnels des bâtiments ils ont dû
faire des photos sur site des relevés et
tracer leur propre plan effectivement à
l'époque où les faits d'avoir les outils
que demain aujourd'hui les imprimantes
des trente ans on a formé tickets t va
mener réussi
des sons assister les temps qui ont
précédé l'ouverture l'équipe a travaillé
nuit et jour pour finaliser
l'installation le 25 mai 1991 le parc
ouvre ses portes
thierry coltier s'en souvient pascal
pierre ville c'est le soulagement
dans un effort moment j'ai écouté toutes
les équipes avec une charrette nerfs
solides avec toujours mentionné qu est
ce que il y aura des des visiteurs il y
en a le parc en attire plus de 200000
chaque année depuis 30 ans il fait
désormais partie du paysage culturel des
yvelines mais aussi d'île de france et
d'ailleurs si vous l'avez manqué le
dernier numéro du 7-8 culture était
justement consacrée aux 30 ans du parc
france miniature une émission à
retrouver en replay sur notre site
internet tv 78 points comme bien sûr
notre application mobile voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]